je m'appelle et lillers vie j'ai 67 ans
je suis architecte urbaniste de
formation et ce soir je vais vous parler
d'une école préparatoire et
d'orientation pour ceux qui cherchent
leur voie
retenez bien s'appelle le lift fabrique
de talent je ne vais pas vous décrire
son programme son cursus à peine ses
méthodes
mais vous trouverez tout ça sur le web
par contre je vais vous raconter une
histoire
pourquoi et comment le livre a été créé
c'est l'histoire d'une passion pour
l'enseignement et c'est l'histoire d'une
mission pour l'éveil
comme je suis timide émotif et
perfectionniste je ne vais pas quitter
ce papier ce ne sont ni les livres ni
les statistiques qui m'ont amené au
constat navrant du taux élevé d'échec
scolaire et de leur cause depuis que
j'ai quitté les bancs de l'école
j'accompagne des jeunes adultes dans
l'enseignement supérieur
c'est donc à force d'expériences
d'observation et de discussions que j'ai
pris la mesure du décalage sans cesse
croissant entre la structure de l'école
ces programmes ploie zone et ses
méthodes
un pur kate d'enseignement et le désir
pourtant très vif qu'ont les jeunes
d'apprendre de comprendre et de se
réaliser dans un monde en pleine
mutation
par ailleurs l'école ne se caractérise
pas par son empathie ni l'attention
qu'elle porte à la diversité des
personnalités qui la villa fréquente
pourtant il n'y a pas de connaissance
possible sans connaissance et
acceptation de soi il n'ya pas
d'ambition envisageable sans avoir fait
le tour de ses propres potentialités et
des motivations qui la soutiennent il
n'y a pas de choix possible sans avoir
un minimum de connaissances et de
compréhension du monde dans lequel on
évolue
un enseignant c'est un expert qui se
souvient des difficultés qu'il a eu
avant d'être experts car la transmission
ne peut se faire qu en expliquant le
chemin on ne peut pas comprendre ni
instruire sur n'a pas connu
échec et surtout comment tirer des
conclusions pour s'en relever
je m'appelle elie j'ai 7 ans je joue
simple est dans blanche neige et les
sept nains je suis tétanisé j'ai oublié
mon texte
j'ai le coeur qui 30 j'ai le coeur qui
bat je tremble tous or tout se brouille
l'ofs l'esprit la vue je pleure
quelqu'un me tend un mouchoir pour
essuyer les larmes
nikos boys don't cry et je suis là
penaud honteux je quitte la scène
je retrouverai plusieurs fois encore
mais comme figurants muet je suis timide
et personne ne vient à mon secours
je grandis j'ai du poil entre 12 et 15
ans tout change en moi et autour de moi
c'est le chaos
la guerre au congo violente et me montre
sa laideur il n'y a personne pour
m'expliquer pour me dire m expliquer
tout ce qui se passe les changements qui
opère mes amis partis en exil
je dois tout reconstruire alors moi qui
était toujours premier de ma promotion
sans comprendre
je vais m'installer avec les grands au
dernier rang et j'arrive à des places à
dépasser le dernier de classe je
décroche
je veux changer de filière mais là-bas
au congo rien ne convient aux ambitions
de mes parents il me faut un temps pour
remonter la pente
presque seule une main tendue mais coûte
j'existe genre construit un nouveau
projet intuitivement je sens qu'il est
temps que je parte que je sorte de mon
isolement que je découvre le monde
j'entreprends des études d'architecturé
pour lesquelles je ne suis pas préparé
et puis ici d'autres impératifs
m'appelle les inégalités sociales les
premières luttes urbaines
le péril nucléaire les guerres injustes
celle de celle du vietnam
tout cela n 9 pour moi et m'interpelle
je deviens jeunes est gentil rebelles
déçu et désemparé je me brise dans un
parcours chaotique que je suis prêt à
abandonner sans trop savoir quoi faire
d'ailleurs jusqu'à ce qu'un professeur
de remplacement au lieu de m'interroger
sur des matières académiques qui très
sincèrement je ne vois pas très bien
l'utilité moi qui en plus de ça n'ait
aucune mémoire me tend un livre ouvert
et me demande dans gears 3 pages
je le prends au coeur du troisième reich
albert speer ministre de la guerre est
architecte d'hitler il est question de
la responsabilité de l'architecte
je découvre une discipline aux
incidences politiques économiques
sociales et culturelles
mais finalement non et il pas de même de
toute pratique de tous métiers
n'avons nous pas par nos pensées sur
tous nos actes une responsabilité et une
action possible sur ces différents
niveaux
ça ça me parle ça fait sens pour moi au
terme de deux heures de discussions le
professeur mme enjoint de ne pas
abandonner mes études
edit m'attendre à la rentrée quelles que
soient mes résultats
il s'appelle maurice culot ne seront pas
toujours d'accord mais il devient un
moment tu aurais mon ami
j'apprends à ses côtés que je peux que
je dois penser m'exprimer communiquer en
toute liberté mais que la liberté a un
prix et que je suis et que cela suppose
que je m'interroge que je prenne des
risques que je cherche et que je vérifie
pour être responsable pertinents
rigoureux et surtout cohérent cette
prise de conscience
autant que ce don de confiance change ma
vie je reprends mes études avec passion
et je les termine avec grande
distinction
le jour où je reçois mon diplôme l'école
m'offre un poste d'assistant d'étudiants
je deviens enseignants plutôt
accompagnateurs et facilitateur de
projets mais dix premières années
d'enseignement sont centrés sur ce que
j'ai appris ce qui me semble bien juste
et beau sur l'a30 sur la transmission de
ce que je
lee et à la fin de cette période je
donne un cours d'arts appliqués au xxème
siècle nous étudiants d'art secteur
intérieur à mons
ils sont surpris par la diversité et la
simultanéité des courants de pensée qui
émaillent le 20e siècle
alors que l'ombre et l'esprit du
rationnel du boss plane encore occupés
et domine de les penser et leur
formation
mais la pensée n'est pas unique
alors je tente l'expérience je les mets
en relaxation profonde à même le sol
entre les tables à dessin dans une sorte
d'hypnose ericksonienne et jallet
promène fermer les yeux
imaginez d'abord dans une ville une rue
des bâtiments un parc un monument puis
dans une maison flanqué entre deux
arbres un hall un escalier et enfin dans
une chambre du mobilier une fenêtre
elles sont toutes imaginaire elles ne
sont jamais décrites je leur demande de
nous ramener de proposer pour chaque
voyage cinq productions dessins
maquettes écrit collage ce qu'ils
veulent pour partager leur vision la
cage est ouverte
ils font du hors piste il explore un
vent de liberté et de créativité souffle
sur les heureux sur des élèves une même
structure donne lieu à autant de villes
de maisons et de chambre qu'il ya
d'élèves
il n'est plus question de bien ou de mal
de baudelaire mais de s'exprimer
intuitivement librement et son jugement
il s'agit d'éveiller leur potentiel
créatif et de leur donner confiance en
leur capacité à inventer et aussi pour
communiquer trouver les moyens
nécessaires y compris ceux qu'ils n'ont
pas appris des étudiants enthousiastes
en part à d'autres professeurs
l'un d'eux interloqué par l'exercice ce
qui est proposé leur dis mais c'est
n'importe quoi
la prochaine fois il est des vies vous
emmènera à la piscine
informé de la remarque est piqué au vif
je le vois deux jours plus tard ils sûrs
et or chers amis
croyez bien que si j'étais certain de
leur apprendre quelque chose dans la
piscine
je les emmène dans l'eure mais je ne
suis pas maître nageur et je devais
songé ultérieurement à la transversalité
des savoirs et que finalement il ya
moyen d'apprendre des tas de choses
habib sy on peut y enseigne expérimenter
les sciences principe de newton
d'archimède et vases communicants on
peut y enseigner la chimie la biologie
la bactériologie l'anatomie les règles
d'hygiène on peut apprendre à dépasser
ses limites
développer la confiance en soi et on
peut même parler des problèmes de l'eau
dans le monde et des inégalités dans sa
répartition tout en s'amusant et en
apprenant à nager c'est fou ce que ces
richissimes
mais comment fait tout ce qu'ils font ce
qui nous entoure cependant un incident
tu en perds mon enthousiasme
une étudiante en larmes
crac pendant qu'elle dessine sa chambre
rêver elle se confie à moi dans
l'ignorance totale de ses condisciples
elle viendra bien dilemme
son père est à l'hôpital à l'article de
la mort elle ne l'a plus vu depuis qu'il
l'a quitté
lorsqu'il est prêt à peine une enfant
elle se demande si elle doit aller le
voir ou pas moi je ne suis pas
thérapeute éclaireurs bienveillant
peut-être mais pas tes rappeuse alors je
n'ai pas de réponse mais je l'aide à
trouver les siennes et je comprends à ce
moment là que le parcours d'un étudiant
n'est pas étranger ni à son état
émotionnel ni à sa condition physique
sur ce je n'ai plus envie de donner des
cours aux cloisonné basé sur des livres
lus et prémâché pour des élèves qui avec
un peu de chance ne rend que ne
retiendront pas grand chose
j'ai ouvert une brèche un filon plein de
ressources et de possibles et je ne sens
pas prêt à explorer les que me propose
un horaire élargie une carte blanche que
je décline et j'envoie la place une
bibliographie à l'attention des
étudiants jeu poursuit et développe
macquarie un architecte
un jour face à une mission pour laquelle
je n'ai aucune compétence mais alors
aucune compétence
un ami me dit la question n'est pas de
savoir si tu sais où si tu ne sais pas
et lee la question est de savoir
as-tu envie de le faire je relève le
défi et j'apprends ce que je ne sais pas
et c'est ainsi que j'ai hâte que j'ai
appris que j'ai pratiqué plusieurs
métiers aussi divers instructif que
passionnant retour à l'enseignement dix
ans plus tard j'ai 44 ans et l'école de
la cambre confie la direction d'une
option me vient à l'esprit cette phrase
de hannah arendt l'éducation et le point
où se décident si nous aimons assez le
monde pour en assumer la responsabilité
et de plus le sauver de cette ruine qui
serait inévitable sans ce renouvellement
est censé arriver de jeunes et de
nouveaux venus
c'est également avec l'éducation que
nous décidons si nous aimons assez nos
enfants pour ne pas les rejeter de notre
monde ni les abandonnés à eux mêmes ni
leur enlever leur chance d'entreprendre
quelque chose de neuf
quelque chose que nous n'avions pas
anticipé que n'avions ni prévu ni
entrevue mais les préparer davance à la
tâche de renouveler réinventer un monde
commun et partagé la réputation de
l'atelier ne me précède liberté de
penser de recherche sont alliés à ces
vérités exigences et rigueur que suppose
le fait de marcher en dehors des clous
au professeur accompagné d'un assistant
pour encadrer pendant cinq années
les jeunes dessinent est une guerrière
créative
je préfère une équipe élargie de 8
personnes réunies pour leur compétence
et non pour l'assimiler et non pour la
similitude de nos points de vue bien au
contraire je me rends compte aussi de la
rapidité avec laquelle le monde change
au rythme de l'obsolescence de certaines
matières enseignées
on ne peut pas tout apprendre dans une
école alors être autonome en phase avec
soi même et les autres l écoute des
changements rapides et imprévisible se
doter de la capacité de décoder pour les
anticiper et s'adapter sur les
conditions indispensables pour vivre et
construire le monde de demain qui évolue
avec célérité au point que l'on que l'on
prévoit qu'avant 20 ans écoutez bien on
prévoit qu'avant 20 ans 70% des métiers
qui seront pratiqués n'existe pas encore
cela veut dire aussi que bon nombre de
métiers que l'on pratique aujourd'hui
auront disparu en maître ignorant
j'ai mis en oeuvre avec et pour les
étudiants des méthodes de travail basé
sur l'inversion des rôles classiques
professeurs actifs étudiants passif
cela permet à chacun de s'exprimer
pleinement
en devenant proactive dans ses
apprentissages au pouvoir et à
l'autorité
je préfère le respect la confiance
l'estimé mutuelle l'écouté la
collaboration c'est comme ça qu'on
apprend le plus les uns des autres et
dans mes années de maturité 3 à jonction
identifie des options trust nothing and
nobody
ne croyez rien de ce que l'on vous dit
vous devez tout vérifier par vous même
et vous devez faire des choix que vous
devrez ensuite assumé mais que cela ne
vous empêche pas d'essayer ce que l'on
vous propose
fuck de skate car l'échelle des
interventions n'a aucune importance
chacune de vos skis ses actions exprimez
votre projet de société pour chaque
proposition votre responsabilité est
engagée proposent leur responsabilité
politique économique sociale et
culturelle
pensez toujours en philosophe et enfin
fuck the woods
parce que bon dieu vers elles sont
faites pour être transgressée il n'y a
pas de progrès ni d'évolution possible
sans cette condition là et demain
j'espère que vous serez non pas des
soldats mais des guerriers qui crée
réinvente de les règles en fonction des
combats et pour vous les jeunes les
combats et les défis ne font que
commencer
le résultat de cet enseignement
ce sont des jeunes bien dans leur peau
qui entreprennent leur vie et
gourmandises et s'épanouissent dans une
grande diversité de parcours et de
pratiques qu'ils choisissent en
conscience quand ils ne les ont pas eu
même inventé
le lift fabrique de talent écoles
préparatoires et d'orientation fond de
sa pédagogie sur ses expériences
elle a été créée parce qu'il ya un vide
dans l'enseignement secondaire qui ne
peut pas être comblé dans l'enseignement
supérieur ni universitaire le lift c'est
cet entre deux c'est une école
propédeutique ou les tuteurs partagent
leurs connaissances et construisaient
savoir avec les étudiants est ouverte
sur le monde à 360 degrés c'est aussi
une école de la vie elle offre un
parcours dense exigeant résolument
transversale transdisciplinaire
transculturelle transculturelle 30
sociale et germaine trans-générationnel
elle est ancrée dans la contemporanéité
parce que le passé d'un intérêt pour
nous que si elle fait sens dans le monde
nous construisons après cinq mois
d'existence
les résultats dépassent les espérances
plaisir d'apprendre curiosité
implication intérêt pour la
transversalité dans tous les domaines
proposés structuration de la pensée du
discours qualités relationnelles accrue
amélioration de l'expression personnelle
découverte de talents inexploré
clarification et construction d'un
projet d'avenir
un jeune ami étudiant du lift m'a
demandé à deux reprises et dit pourquoi
tu crées le lift égoïstement lui ai-je
dit je les crée pour moi pour explorer
éclairé et affiner ma propre voie en
croisant et en enrichissant de la tienne
je l' ai aussi fait pour une alternative
un lieu on apprend à apprendre à lui on
apprend à s'apprendre pour construire et
consolider la confiance est le signe de
soi acquérir des outils de recherche de
communication élargir ses connaissances
découvrir la nécessaire 30 la nécessaire
transversalité des des savoirs et faire
de nouvelles expériences et aussi
s'émerveiller encore du monde avec les
25 heures extraordinaire qui nous
accompagnent ensemble nous pouvons faire
la différence et la différence elle est
virale et contaminante
cette école est pensé en hommage à mes
parents qui m'ont soutenu
à mon père ce phare aux étudiants et
professeurs qui m'ont accompagné surtout
à quelques quelques étudiants et
quelques professeurs qui m'ont instruits
et qui m'ont inspiré à vous tous midi ma
porte est ouverte
j'espère que nos chemins se croiseront
pour construire ensemble un bond
inattendu plus responsable plus juste
plus aimant et plus beau je vous
remercie de votre écoute et je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée